foreign
Chicago what's up Robert
hey John thanks for having me on the
show of course brother you're doing well
today
um we're getting there man what's up
uh so I was uh I was raised Christian
growing up but I've pretty much been an
Atheist my whole life okay
um my wife is also an atheist but she
believes that religion is brainwashing
and it's bad okay I disagree with her on
this actually I actually I follow
scripture and religion and I like
hearing about it like on the Ramsay show
okay
um I want to send our kids to a private
Christian school and maybe church if
they're interested in going
um so am I doing the right thing how do
I guide them in life but not push them
and how do I approach my wife on this
hmm
feels like there's like five questions
five questions there I'm sorry
um so I
let me let me say back to you what I
heard okay
um you don't believe in the
fairy tale somebody's listening to all
of your the Harry Potter parts of the
Bible but you like the structure you
like the morality you like the if you
follow these rules you're probably gonna
have a better life if you don't kill
people you probably have a better life
if you don't lie and cheat and steal
right so you like that part of it and
you like the structure
your wife on the other hand thinks
that's the problem with everything all
the world's ills are because of
religious people
yeah
I think you got it yep that's it
so why do you want to send your kids
there because you want to learn that
structure or just because it's
comfortable because that's what you know
uh because I want them to learn that
structure and I like the conservative
background and the good principles that
it teaches so what happens if one of
your kids comes to you and says daddy
will you baptize me in the name of
whatever
Jesus Christ are you in would you do
that for them absolutely okay
um
and here's why I'm asking that
it's a tall order
for a kid
what's the right way to say this I'm
struggling with my words
um
if you send a kid to a private Christian
School they're gonna get the
Christian message
right
they're gonna get the full package and
as a child they as much as our
overly sophisticated
Parents try to make kids which is just
so insane what we do to kids these days
they will not be able to differentiate
as little kids they just won't
and what I mean by differentiate they
might be able to know like I don't know
if Santa Claus is real that possibly but
and it they won't be able to
differentiate I think
teacher so-and-so is lying to me that's
where it gets more challenging okay and
so if you're sending them just for the
structure but you're gonna fight them on
the other things they learn and what
they the other things they come to on
their own then I would suggest maybe
that's not that's not you're going to
confuse your kids
um if you are sitting them there because
no man I want them to be open hold
belief with an open hand
and I'm gonna honor and support and love
whatever they come back with
then I think that's that's pretty
amazing of you and good for you and I'll
be all for it where you're going to run
into problems if mom is trying to
torpedo this whole thing y'all got to be
on the same page
yeah that makes sense yeah
is she totally against this
I've mentioned it a couple times at
first she totally was but recently I
kind of brought it up really quick and
she kind of warmed up to the idea
what do you want uh I'm at the Starbucks
line and by the way can our kids worship
Jesus Christ Lord God savior ready to go
that's pretty much what it was
[Music]
um yeah I wouldn't do it like that
um yeah I've been kind of like testing
the water
you're ridiculous but but but
I understand so uh I think it's worth a
sit-down conversation
have you sat down and had that full
conversation with your wife like you
explained to me
no no I haven't about not about your
kids but about you
um yeah yeah we've talked about that
okay and she still married you anyway
why
because she loves me oh
I love lots of people I'm not married to
Robert
is she gonna be okay if your kids come
back as believing Christian kids
yeah yeah I think she would be okay
so
what's your question
I I guess
just how do I how do I approach her on
this what kind of how should I start the
conversation and
and feel her out on it
uh I don't
I think you're trying to be awfully
political on a really important topic
and so I think Honesty and directness
and dignity and respect are the approach
here not
strategies and tactics
um I would sit down if I was you and say
okay they've reached age X we both don't
like what's happening in public schools
partridge in a pear tree whatever store
narrative that y'all have talked about
there
I drew great benefit from the structure
from the morality from the kindness from
all those pieces
from this structure and I want to give
our children opportunity to have that
same
structure
this is important to me would you allow
us to to give us a shot and here's
here's the other thing that I I talk to
parents all the time about homeschooling
and private schools and this and that
and you can always just switch
right
yeah if your kids come home and say hey
I gotta work on my memory verse and
your wife just goes into a
you know a rage just start setting the
house on fire you can always just put
the kids back in public school
yeah yeah that's true too is that fair
yeah yeah definitely
um I guess my other question too was is
how do I guide my kids down this path
but not push them you know how do I know
when when they don't want to continue
with it if they're maybe they won't tell
me
I don't know that they get a vote
that's a lot of pressure to put on a kid
if there's abuse I'd say in my house I
missed it
um we put my kid in a private school uh
wasn't a faith-based school it's just a
it was just a private school and they
had a lot of beliefs that we had like no
screens and you know they learned math
by
doing things like building things and
cooking things and things like that
super hippie school is awesome
um what I didn't know is that my son's
teacher
couldn't stand him
and that he was really struggling with
connectivity with students and I blamed
him and I told him things that I'm
ashamed of like suck it up you got to
get over it dude you need to quit fill
in the blank until one day my wife had
the courage to go down there and she sat
down and talked to everybody we and we
had both talked but with the different
people but she finally got it and she
picked our kid up and walked out the
door
and we have never been back
and so when it comes to hey we're going
to this school I think a lot of times we
give kids that option and that's that's
choice is so heavy on them
and that's a burden that I'm not going
to put on my kids hey we go to this
school this is the school you're going
to
except if they're being abused
if they're in a situation where the
adults in that school don't like my kid
don't want my kid to succeed want my kid
to not be there then I'm gonna gladly
I'll help you out and I'll take my kid
out other than that I'm not going to put
him in that situation so I would tell
your kids hey we're going to a new
school how old are your kids
well just one right now how old
one years old yep oh my gosh lead with
that Robert a one-year-old
one-year-olds don't even can't
you especially don't get a vote until
you can poop in a in a toilet
Fair yes Fair
um
man I thought your kids were like nine
and six or something okay so you have a
one-year-old yeah they don't get a vote
homie just send them to school
okay
you are way overthinking this
yeah that's what I do
yeah how about don't do that man you're
gonna make yourself nuts
all right
um if yeah yes
just put your kid into school he'll
they'll be fine
um I think you need to be prepared for
what happens if are we gonna honor our
kids belief that the same way we expect
other people to honor ours
and I say that same thing to my friends
who are Christian whose kids come and be
like I don't know if I buy all of this
I always tell them you have you are not
a Crossroads that the kid just laid
before you
are you going to choose a relationship
in the long-term game here
are you going to choose
dogma and being right right now
one of those May cost you your
relationship with your kid forever
and I'm not saying parents give up on
their belief kids he's nice they're
going to go to church with me all that
stuff is still gonna happen
but I'm talking about beating kids up
over belief which I've been working at
universities my whole life that that's
I've just seen it over and over and over
and over again parents sacrificing the
long-term relationship with their kids
over small battles and so you're gonna
you argue and your wife gonna have to be
totally on the same page when it comes
to that
because trying to torpedo a
three-year-old or a four-year-old with
well you know that's not true I mean
that's just man it's just cruel quite
honestly
and Robert he's won
one years old
I know that you know this but you've got
the rest of his sweet little life to
worry about him
just put them in school
and if you choose a private Christian
School fantastic great
um
honor the rules and regulations and
honor the spirit of the place
and be supportive of the teachers and be
supportive of the curriculum and don't
get mad when they teach things that you
don't necessarily agree with because you
signed up and sent your kid there
or do what I do I send my kids to public
school
and I have taken ownership in my home of
their spiritual Direction and the things
that they are learning and I'm actually
grateful for the stuff that they learn
in the public school because they come
home and ask me about it and I get to
teach them before they head off into the
real world and learn about it and don't
have me they have Google instead
and so that's just the path I've chosen
I don't know there's a right or wrong
path here other than a mom and dad who
are completely and totally attached and
attuned to that kid
and are willing to sometimes
keep their mouths shut and say that's
very interesting tell me more about that
what does that look like
I would love to know more what do you
think Daddy oh I'm not telling you that
that's just for me I love hearing what
you have to say about it
that's hard
that's the long-term play
the long game